la bd avec un personnage de légende au
festival de la bande dessinée angoulême
chang le héros de tintin au tibet et du
lot sud lotus bleu en chair et en os sur
place pour las pour le 60e anniversaire
de la naissance de tintin hergé
c'était en effet inspiré de ce
personnage un chinois zhang dan zhang ze
les prononcer tout à fait efficacement
chang est aujourd'hui âgé de 81 ans et
il est sculpteur
les millions d'admirateurs de tintin il
est chang l'ami fidèle berger
l'inspirateur de tintin au tibet et
quelques-uns le connaissent par son vrai
nom ching chong jane et toute son oeuvre
de sculpteur ce buste d'hergé par
exemple réalisé en 1987
sa dernière réalisation le buste du
président de la république dévoiler ici
pour nous et pour la première fois dans
un film qui s'intitule mois chang qui
n'a été montré aujourd'hui qu'à quelques
privilégiés
chang terre près de 80 ans raconte
comment il a aidé hergé a créé sa femme
indigne que la douleur mais enfin il a
changé ton soleil comme technique de
dessin et cela est plus lisible et c'est
surtout l'histoire est tout à fait
réelle ceux ci se dit que il faut
si vous travaillez d'après les
événements authentique votre livre cela
aura valeur historique pour l'avenir à
la votre livre a toujours existé et au
milieu des planches originales du lotus
bleu il revoit pour la première fois
depuis les années 30
chang réprime son émotion en pensant à
sa prophétie et à son ami disparu
rg
à noter que demain le 19/20 vous
emmènera au festival d'angoulême